Where I come from?
I’m not connected to one place
but my connection to all places is:
wherever I go, I keep asking questions.
as a little boy I was the one getting on the
nerves
of the teachers, my parents and my friends
by asking “Why?
Why?
Why?”
This little boy is now a journalist
and keeps doing one thing
asking questions.
My work takes me every day to the Arab region.
I see a lot of potential and energy in the
younger generation.
They raise their voice for issues they care
for
but is anyone listening?
Why aren’t they part of the political decisions?
Why can’t they be who they want to be?
And why are they not able to speak freely
about everything they care for?
That’s why I want to give the younger generation
a platform
to express themselves freely,
be who they want to be
and raise their questions.